[Musique]
bien bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui nous
sommes à peterhof dans la banlieue de
saint pétersbourg c'est ici que se
trouve le palais de peterhof bien connu
dans le monde entier pour ses jardins et
ses fontaines y magnifique construit
depuis plus de 300 ans
pierre legrand fondateur de saint
pétersbourg a fait construire ici sa
résidence d'honneur qui a donné son nom
à la ville
en trois siècles la ville s'est beaucoup
pas grandi aujourd'hui c'est un
important centre scientifique éducatif
et touristique pour la capitale du nord
mais son joyau reste le palais en partie
conçu par l'empereur lui même
c'est à peterhof que vit et travaille
notre invité d'aujourd'hui xavier giraud
des
il est originaire d'orléans il est venu
s'installer en russie et il va nous
faire découvrir les secrets de son
métier l'horlogerie d'ailleurs il est
temps de faire sa connaissance
[Musique]
vous aviez organes
enchanté de faire ta connaissance à six
mois demain bienvenue à la manufacture
akata merci tu peux vous dire un petit
peu plus sur la manufacture aurait si
c'est effectivement le bâtiment
principal de lusine d'accord fondée en
et mekki d'accès aux origines date
pierre le grand mais ces 121 on vous
fait un anniversaire alors oui
effectivement effectivement c'est cette
année les 300 ans de la manufacture
wallace a vu que maintenant que toi que
tu travailles ici je travaille depuis
quatre ans d'accord loger horloger à
l'assemblage pour un keita et un autre
label récemment créé intéressant tu me
fais visiter allons-y allons-y super
là on est dans l'atelier d'usinage
principal de lusine d'accord donc une
mère de deux tours ici un beau coup
monofil quantités importantes tous ont
fait le récit par les opérations de
taille âge d'une mécanisme d'accord tout
le mécanisme matières brutes produit
final sous une même marque sous un même
toit verticalisation complète dans la
production sas et ça c est très rare
dans la vie et c'est rare c'est ça à
plus de 10 dans le monde il ya beaucoup
d'employés au total 70 personnes on
certains sont à temps partiel oui
notamment des vétérans qui transmettent
leur savoir faire des gens plus jeunes
et certains viennent sont des personnes
qui sont appelés uniquement pour mettre
en route certaines de ces machines qu'on
voit ici quand tu parles de vétérans
parce que je regardais machines elles
ont un certain âge elle fonctionne
encore c'est des machines qui ne sont
pas calculés pour tomber en panne il n'y
a pas d' obsolète sens programmés de
même que le mécanisme en raquettes a
d'ailleurs
votre clientèle luxe
qui a qui ont acquis vous vendez vos
montres ça peut être des gens qui ont
une collection déjà très large de pièces
des gens des primo accédants
l'horlogerie aussi
des gens personnes qui veulent
finalement s'acheter un mois en bourse
de l'histoire c'est quand même la plus
ancienne entreprise enregistrée de
russie un héritage de taille de pierre
et ça va être des produits ludiques
accessibles
et qui sont qui raconte finalement 1
1 un passé certes mais aussi un futur
avec quand même une usine à un morceau
d'histoire cliff viner qui se projette
aussi bien
[Musique]
dis moi ça sent l'histoire ici ici tout
voilà dans le musée dans le musée de
lusine et on a un concentré de voilà
deux objets de l'époque soviétique de
l'époque tsariste oui j'ai l'impression
que les montres vont à l'envers oui
c'est normal ça c'est ça encore assez
unique au monde mais il ya toujours une
histoire derrière oui c'est pour montrer
finalement que certains astres delà de
l'ong delà de notre de notre chère et
petites galaxies way tourne
effectivement un sens inverse les uns
par rapport aux autres notamment le l'un
des plus proches qui étend la 20e levée
de facile pour lire l'heure la 1,36 à
l'envers non la lune tourne
effectivement à l'envers autour de la
terre alors effectivement ça c'est assez
là c'est une pièce qui fait parler
d'elle on la perd 11 ils m'ont tout à
fait classique mais tout mouvement a été
finalement copier on a un effet miroir
en production pourquoi finalement les
roues surmontées dans un sens un sens
inverse c'est que là c'est pour tromper
l'ennemi oui c'est ça
[Musique]
c'est là la partie la plus importante le
plus compliqué
ici on pourrait dire que c'est
l'entonnoir ou
si les composants sont défectueux c'est
exactement ce niveau-là de production
dans l usine qu'on va décréter les
défaites des défauts finalement elles
ont été fabriquées en amont ici ce donc
l'assemblage l'assemblage donc
l'assemblage des mécanismes l'assemblage
de la montre final premier des contrôles
surtout question qui me vient à l'esprit
aussi c'est aujourd'hui on est de plus
en plus dans les téléphones et montre
connecter à ce que est ce que ça risque
pas de faire disparaître la montre
mécanique la montre à quartz elle a fait
disparaître vraiment merga nick wey
alors elle a essayé et à la perdue et la
masse patron je suis remplacé par
simplement par un autre objets obsolètes
qui sera bientôt avec une durée de vie
précise rennes la montre bracelet
mécanique c'est un c'est de l'art
finalement là est un morceau d'histoire
c'est un morceau de pour en l'occurrence
pour ceux d'histoire russe finalement
ici et rien ne peut ne rien pour
l'instant
c'est ton bureau c'est ça effectivement
c'est bon c'est mon bureau je suis
occupé surtout sur la marque donc qu'est
créée récemment
ya quelques années de cela qu'il a marre
qu'on manufacture impériale de peterhof
c'est un projet pilote ont ça nous a
aidés beaucoup en interne a finalement
avoir une autre approche qualité par
rapport à ce segment qui est du segment
luxe d'accord et donc là j'ai une montre
devant moi là on contrôle finaux avec
une petite correction à faire au niveau
du haut niveau de la de la masse ou six
ans voilà donc pour une onde bien
spécifique on met le meilleur le chef
moi je suis juste un acteur de la
acteurs de la chaîne c'est un vieux on a
sonné pour xavier n'est pas seulement
horloger il travaille chez nous comme
ingénieur chargé de l'introduction de
nouvelles technologies
il est aussi chargé de former nos
horloger qui travaillaient ici avant lui
et
on organise justement ce nouveau projet
avec lui
sans lui on n'y arriverait pas
chaque montre est spécifique selon la
demande du client voilà c'est le
processus comme un costume sur mesure
différence pour nous ici mes yeux du
prêt-à-porter quoi je vois qu'il ya même
des cloches avec ton nom oui ils vont
tes propres pièces c'est ça comme
n'importe quel
j'aime être dans son métier n'importe
quel artisan on prouve qu'on a nos
outils à main on appelle ça un con que
l'on fabrique tout même que l'on va qui
vont nous suivre toute autre carrière et
j'en ai ça par exemple ça c'est un outil
rebond il ça va pas refaire cela ça fait
là bas ça fait depuis depuis 90 8 1 98
qui me qui me suivent la préparation est
toujours plus longues que l'opération
l'opération en elle-même qui met ces
raisons que juste mettre une vis il
s'agissait pas de prendre la vie je
comprends que n'importe quel tournevis
et et allons-y gaiement non vraiment
c'est ta d'état des mèches par exemple
en laiton il faut que le tournevis use à
la vis la ville doit rester immaculée
avec un poly parfait et le tournevis lui
par qu'on va s'user et on va le refaire
la main ce que la ville avis va rester
dans la montre finalement qui sera
destiné aux clients et les finitions et
en haut de gamme il doit doit y avoir
aucune offre aucune trace d'intervention
de
[Musique]
chaque détail du mécanisme est une
oeuvre d'art si on peut dire on pourrait
prendre une pièce est seul à mettre
autour du cou
et quand on assemble si mécanismes il
faut faire attention à ne pas l'abîmer
on lui causer un défaut quel coin et
pièces sont très petit et xavier s'est
parfaitement faire ça il a des mains en
or
il peut remonter ou démonter à peu près
n'importe quelle montre qu'il a vu une
fois
grande question comment es tu arrivé
dans l'horlogerie pourquoi qu'est ce qui
a changé mon grand père qui était qui
était en anticorps horloger qui avait
aussi coûté environ loger lui-même mais
surtout antiquaires et j'ai baigné dans
mon enfance finalement pas remis parmi
beaucoup tendues surtout un produit les
montres de poche et montres anciennes ce
casse-tête aux classes est encore les
montres les montres de poche avait
encore encore une grosse part de marché
et
donc c'est dans le blanc le jeu ancien
finalement le patrimoine historique
horloger de la france et en étant
immense on le voit dans tous les cantons
dans tous les palets finalement
d'ailleurs de saint pétersbourg
énormément de pendules sont d'origine
française la grande époque torje
française
xavier giraud des aînés en 1982 à
orléans ses parents sont agents de la
poste mais xavier est très vite attirée
par le monde de l'horlogerie
grâce à son grand père qui tient un
magasin d'antiquités ou il répare des
pendules anciennes à 16 ans vous aviez
fait un premier ça chez un horloger et
décide alors de s'orienter dans cette
voie il passe un crp d'horlogerie dans
une école parisienne tout en faisant son
apprentissage à orléans dans le cadre du
programme d'échangé européen léonardo
destiné aux formations professionnelles
il part pour un an en 2002 à leeds en
angleterre
revenu en france il décide de continuer
à sa formation à rennes pour acquérir
une nouvelle qualification en horlogerie
reconnu en suisse en 2004 il part
travailler à château à côté de genève
pour y rejoindre un grand groupe
horloger en 2008 il est recruté par un
autre groupe suisse qui l'envoie à
moscou pour y travailler dans son
service après vente
après quatre ans en russie une autre
maison suisses prestigieuses lui propose
un poste en chine à pékin il accepte et
un an et demi plus tard il continue son
périple à shanghai où il reste deux ans
après ses expériences chinoises xavier
décide de rentrer en suisse mais s'il
est finalement attiré par l' aventure de
raketa une prestigieuse manufacture
horlogère russe tombé en décrépitude et
relevé quelques années plus tôt par un
homme d'affaires franco britannique
désireux de poser enfin ses valises il
s'installe alors à peterhof où se trouve
la manufacture
en 2020 il se marie avec anastasia avec
qui il a un enfant lire
parce que il ya des choses qui sont
surpris en arrivant en russie les choses
auxquelles vraiment tu t'attendais pas
alors je m'entendais pas
estimant avoir une gêne pas une
résistance fait une certaine inertie par
rapport à la mise en place de dans le
travail sont parle chaque jour
de process de production de management
moderne en russie n
non seulement il en prison n'ont pas
c'est pas tellement voulu et il yal
usines les process évidemment
soviétiques ont voulu être
modernisés même certain
remis à plat et sur le long terme ça m'a
j'ai toujours été surpris christian on
en revient finalement à cela on en
revient c'est assez assez polis ou à
l'ancienne et ça et ça nous suit très
bien et c'est malgré tout productif
c'est ce qu'on appelle inertie
finalement chez nourrir et ses bars
savoir si cela c'est très bien parce
qu'il ya cet esprit de groupe finalement
ainsi que deux communautés une payne pas
une coercition ou le groupe va va
peut-être avoir une influence ça c'est
une pression sur les individus il ya ici
les choses se font de manière naturelle
et et les gens pensent avant tout pas or
parlera par un groupe d'indie l'esprit
devant de la communauté
est-ce que tu as l'intention d'installer
maintenant définitivement enrichi oui là
c'est je pose mes valises en fait enfin
là il s'agit
pensez aussi un peu un famille je me
suis dit récemment avec un enfant un
enfant nouveau-né cdu c'est du projet
projet du projet longtemps je pose mes
valises ici c'est décidé ici fait dix
mois pour moi la prune sont bons
félicitations cassé
[Musique]
piriou yan shi no mercy s'avère très
sympa ici les dents je te présente son
épouse ana c'est à dire bonjour natia
vous parlez français en profite waouh
t'es bien dis donc ça alors vous est-ce
qu'on est ici sommes jabel famille à la
satire d'accord très bien et est donc en
notre appartement est en trop non pour
moi il tout sera livré donc en attendant
temporairement
voilà oui et je vois à la poussette
qu'il y a
il ya eu des changements il ya eu un
combat d'ailleurs ces quatre mois alors
vous parlez français à la maison de
parler en russe que tu parle très bien
le russe mais apparemment tu parles
aussi très bien le français alors oui
voilà l'entrée avec la pratique et lui
il a besoin de très peu un peu de repos
oui oui donc moi j'ai un fils qui leur
pose donc tu pédales à langoiran
c'est bien c'est sympa et puis ça permet
aussi aux petits bébés d'entendre du
français le soir se salue oui du russe
ou de la toute la journée le français le
soir
et culturel effectivement c'est très
bientôt
[Musique]
alors on est à saint pétersbourg tu
étais à moscou avant qu est ce qu est ce
qui vous a donné envie d'aller à saint
pétersbourg
par occasions professionnelles
finalement c'était l'occasion de
retourner en russie après effectivement
moscou chine est là elle a donc j'avais
une belle une belle opportunité de
retourner en milieu industriel dans une
ville dans la ville la plus européenne
finalement de russie et saint
pétersbourg et avec un et du coup mettre
au profit finalement mes compétences
linguistiques et aussi professionnels au
service d'une cette manufacture de la
jeunesse dorée au qatar qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous faites de vous
de votre temps commun géré quand quand
tu n'es pas à l' usine parce que je sais
que tu es un travailleur acharné vous
dans la précision dans le moindre détail
alors et il a tu arrives à le voir quand
même de temps en temps oui bien
évidemment haut de gamme où il passe
beaucoup de temps avec lui de bien
maintenant on fait un peu moins de
ballades mai
puisque l'enfant est encore on est
encore jeune mais finalement
[Musique]
c'est sans fond finalement là le l'offre
culturelle ce soit les arts de la scène
oui
et les musées fillon que ces expositions
temporaires ou permanentes on va on
aller dans des musées au théâtre on
adore le palais ballerini on est
franchement on est des femmes on faisait
des musées aussi parce que moi j'ai
répété que la pratique ou petit peu
j'avais besoin d'acheter un petit coup
d'oeil voilà de faire un en fait mon
itinéraire du temps le musée parce que
je veux montrer tu travailles avec les
touristes c'est ça oui c'est ça je suis
dit francophone je vois ça lui fait
twister fram quoi est ce que tu fais est
ce que tu fais du sport je sais que tu
faisais déjà du vélo ça va faire ça
maintient plutôt bien en forme tu fais
d'autres sports et wii bah oui le long
du cours avec 1 et surtout le socialiser
en faisant du foot
1% du foot je suis loin d'être une une
star alors là c'est
voilà je cours après la balle parfois
elle arrive dans mes bras non mais t'es
moche et méfier et parfois j'arrive même
à relancer te dire que le niveau des
coudes sillonnent ces cas là tu veux me
prendre pour faire un entraînement c'est
avec plaisir match du gardien
aveyronnais avec plaisir du secteur le
foot sera une occasion de voir en plus
un un terrain bien équipée coûte un vide
je suis ton homme courir à ses produits
merci
bien souvent foot je viens passer
régulièrement pour
pour avoir un niveau finalement 2
permettant d'être dans le groupe d
des meilleurs mais je suis dans le
groupe des vétérans voilà ça lui sert il
est ici je viens surtout pour se
stabiliser voire finalement là la
communauté homo le français que j'ai
même pensé
à partir d'un français d'ailleurs bon on
va on y va alors qu'ils étaient partis à
l'agglo
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui te plaît le plus sont
aussi
cette idée de vieilles
de vieilles de vie europe peut-être de
vieille france
des valeurs saines basique famille le
travail l'esprit de communauté une
groupe qu'est ce qu'il y a de commun
pour toi entre la russie et la france
un passé partagé les plus grandes heures
de l'histoire seront été écrite lorsque
la russie et la france étaient était
proche et cd saint pétersbourg à ce
titre à halle et des normes un énorme
patrimoine
commun avec la france qu'est ce que la
france peut apporter à la russie selon
toi du marketing du soft power
une image à travers le cinéma à travers
le à travers les produits finalement qui
ont sauté un certain label cette marque
combine histoire immense en russie et
certains instruments à utiliser je
trouve et qu'est ce que la russie peut
apporter à la france
un esprit téméraires
il ya toujours une marche à descendre le
fond de la piscine et jamais atteint et
l'esprit téméraire et russe à travers
les différentes périodes de l'histoire
l'esprit jusqu'au boutiste peur peut
pour la france pourrait s'inspirer ou
est-ce que le temps peut pas rêver le
plus long
les hivers les hivers saint
pétersbourgeois
la nuit est longue la nuit est longue
carrière ça et je te remercie se fit un
plaisir de partager ces moments avec toi
de découvrir ton univers je te souhaite
une bonne continuation
mais on se voit très bien merci yann
occasion de se revoir à bientôt au
revoir en rien
[Musique]
mais voilà notre émission touche à sa
fin nous l'avons passé à l'examiner
giraudet vous avez découvrir le monde de
l'horlogerie en russie ainsi que cette
magnifique ville de peterhof de nouveaux
lieux de nouvelles personnalités tout
aussi intéressante vous attendre je vous
dis à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
on